у чому полягає ваші ключові претензія до
президентові України
найперша це безумовно корупція
це цей хребет всіх проблем, які у
нас існують
є коло людей які кришують чи є
вибачте за таку лексику але
проте в хату наприклад в
генеральній прокуратурі
правоохоронних інших органів
які які шляхом репресій вибивають
з бізнесу якісь гроші це перше
друге це звичайно ж преференції ми
бачимо, що саме певне коло людей
також одержують монополію на ті чи інші
ресурси та активи ми залишилися сірою зоною
геополітиці ми залишилися території
країною в якій місце не хочуть
приходити
ми залишилися країною яка в
корупційних рейтингах ти теж freedom
house або там transparency international
займає дуже низькі позиції
парламент є таким кнопка натискати
або для того, що режим вирішено водила на
я правильно розумію що ось у всьому цьому
а ви звинувачуєте і повну відповідальність за
те, що відбувається, ви покладаєте на президента
порошенка, безумовно, президентська
позиція має ті повноваження і ту
силою цими ресурсами здатна
змінити ситуацію в країні
вас немає відчуття що захід втомився від
цього і розчарований тим, що відбувається тут я
бачу що захід розчарований та я думаю що
ми точно також українського суспільства
розчарована разом із заходом у тій
нездатності зробити те, що мали
зробити
адже Україна могла зробити таку знаєте
дуже величезний стрибок
навіть порівнюючи з грузії у грузії
вийшло набагато більше насправді
за той час, що вийшло зараз у нас
на жаль і в цьому головна проблема
я навіть ти повинна сказати що і в Європі
ми в якомусь сенсі ми також
розчаровані політики українська
суспільство
Європа могла б зробити більше ні про
конкретних ми бачимо що той чогось
добилася європа це збереження
певних санкцій, але ми бачимо
загравання
і на економічному рівні наприклад
Сьогодні дуже конкретно це північний
потік 2 і цей північний потік дозволить
обхід України транспортувати весь газ
який потрібен Європі тобто по суті
українська газотранспортна мережа вона
буде не потрібна
на сьогоднішній день без позиції Німеччини
наприклад, цей проект неможливо буде
реалізувати
але саме Німеччина на своєму рівні не
заблокувала в рамках європейського
спілки
можливість побудови цього проекту я
оцінюю це як не стратегічне
рішення сьогодні ангела Меркель вона є
заручником позиції німецького бізнесу вона
не займає належну я б сказала жорстку
позицію щодо північного потоку 2
тому що вона розуміє, що вона втратить
підтримку все одно ми бачимо європейські
лідери
вони огранити я би сказала мислять
категоріях електоральних рамок і це
накладає свій відбиток на ті я б
сказала помилки які дозволяють потім
росії вигравати ось цю гібридну
війну, яка вона веде не тільки проти
україни та проти західного світу